the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
alright guys so today is gonna be the
last day of Neutron physics as promised
we're gonna talk about what happens as a
function of time when you perturb the
reactor like you all did about a month
ago did any of you guys notice the old
fashioned analog panel meter that said
reactor period when you were doing your
power manipulations we're gonna do that
today
and you're gonna explore that on the
homework so I'm arranging for all of
your actual power manipulation traces to
be sent with to you so each one you'll
have your own reactor data you'll be
able to describe the reactor period and
see how well it fits our sort of
infinite medium single group equations
which it turns out is not very well but
that's okay because you'll get to
explain the differences first before we
get into transients I wanted to talk a
bit about criticality and perturbing it
so let's say we had our old single group
criticality in relation and I'd like to
analyze just intuitively or mentally
with you guys a few different situations
let's say we're talking about a light
water reactor or a thermal reactor like
the MIT reactor or pretty much all the
reactors we have in this country
what sort of things could you do to
perturb it and how would that affect
criticality like for example let's say
you shoved in a control rod let's take a
sieve the simplest scenario control rods
in what would happen to each of the
terms in the criticality condition and
then what would happen to K effective so
let's just go one by one
does nu ever change ever actually yeah
it does over time you'll start that that
nu right there remember that's a new bar
number of neutrons produced per fission
as you start to burn you to thir or
consume you two or thirty-eight add
neutrons and as you guys saw through a
complicated chain of events on the exam
eventually make plutonium 239 which is a
fissile fuel
the new for 238 it's actually different
than the new for 239 so I don't want to
say that new never changes
it's just that shoving the control rods
into the reactor isn't God not going to
change new but it does change slowly
over time as you build up plutonium what
about Sigma fission if this were a
blended homogeneous reactor our reactor
in a blender what would happen to Sigma
fission as you then shove in an
absorbing material does it change
you say no and I'm gonna adhere
homogeneous so in this case remember if
we define the average Sigma fission as a
sum I'll add bits to it of each
materials volume fraction or let's say
atomic fraction times each materials
Sigma fission if we throw new materials
into the reactor then this homogeneous
Sigma fission does change when we put
materials in or take materials out so
you guys want to revise your idea yes
thank you there's only one other choice
now the question is by how much if you
put in a control rod where let's say the
control rods Sigma fission would be
equal to zero but volume would be equal
to small can't be any more specific than
that how much of an effect do you think
you'll have on Sigma fission very small
so let's say a little down arrow like
that what about Sigma absorption the
volume is still small but the control
rod by definition Sigma absorption
equals huge so what do you think it's
gonna increase a little or a lot quite a
bit now let's look at the diffusion
constant and remember that the diffusion
constant is 1 over 3 Sigma total minus
the average cosine scattering angle
Sigma scattering what do you think is
going to happen to the neutron diffusion
coefficient as you throw in an absorbing
material
something that's got an enormous
absorption cross-section is also going
to have an enormous total cross section
because Sigma total the Sigma absorption
plus Sigma scattering and Sigma
scattering doesn't change that much but
if Sigma absorption goes up Sigma total
goes up if Sigma total goes up then what
happens to the diffusion coefficient yep
it's got a decrease and how does
inserting a control rod change the
geometry very very close so it yeah
you're right the control rod better not
change the geometry but what I do want
to let you remind you of is that this
buckling term includes let's say this
was a one-dimensional infinite slab
Cartesian reactor that little hat over
there means we have some extrapolation
distance remember if we were to draw our
infinite reactor with a thickness a and
we wanted to draw a flux profile on top
of that it would have to be symmetric
about the middle and let's say we had
our axes of this as X and this is flux
flux can't go to zero right at the edge
of the reactor because that would mean
that no neutrons were literally leaking
out so there's going to be some small
extrapolation distance equal to about
two times the diffusion coefficient so
this geometric buckling is actually PI
over the reactor geometry plus two times
the diffusion coefficient and if the
diffusion coefficient goes down
but it's also very very small compared
to the geometric buckling how much does
the buckling change and by how much and
in what direction increases very
slightly so the buckling might increase
very slightly what's the overall net
effect on K effective should go down you
would hope if you put a control rod in
it should make K effective go down
because there's a little decrease here
things kind of cancel out there but the
big one is putting an absorption
material like a control rod in should
make K effective go down and that's the
most intuitive one but you can work out
one term at a time what's generally
going to happen so let's now look at
some other scenarios for the same
criticality condition I'll just rewrite
it so that we can mess it all up again
now we want to go for the case of boil
or avoid your coolant and now we're
getting into the concept of different
feedback mechanisms we've already talked
once about how raising the temperature
of something tends to increase cross
sections in certain ways but now let's
say what would happen if you boil your
coolant if things got really hot and the
water started to boil what do you want
to happen to K effective you want it to
increase decrease thank you you want it
to decrease or else you get a Chernobyl
and we'll talk about how that happened
in a week or two so now let's reason
through each one of these let's assume
that nu doesn't change when you boil the
coolant what about Sigma fission of the
whole reactor
you're taking a little bit of material
out of the reactor by taking liquid
water which is fairly dense and making
it gaseous water which is less dense so
overall there are more fissile atoms in
the reactor proportionally when the
coolant is boiled away then when it's
not so what happens to Sigma fission the
average Sigma fission for the reactor
will go up ever so slightly probably not
enough to matter what about Sigma
absorption if the coolant disappears
yeah water is an absorber hydrogen and
oxygen but really just hydrogen have
some pretty non negligible absorption
coefficients and if those go away then
you're losing a bit of absorber aren't
you oxygen actually it's interesting
oxygen is the lowest thermal cross
section of any element so we can treat
it as pretty much transparent now how
about the diffusion coefficient we've
got the formula for it up there if all
of a sudden your neutrons don't have
much to moderate from or there's not
much to moderate your neutrons yeah your
scattering just like disappears right
but some so does some of your total
cross-section so chances are those
neutrons are going to go farther before
they undergo any given collision because
there's no water in the way so you'd
expect Neutron diffusion to go up and
what about geometric buckling the fusion
goes up then the geometric buckling I'm
just gonna make it really small but the
net effect here once again K effective
goes down we didn't talk about anything
to do with the actual temperature
effects on the cross-sections this is
just a density thing on the coolant
itself so let's now look at that what
about if you have some power spike raise
fuel temperature I'll write it again so
we can mess it up again
so let's say you raise the fuel
temperature and that's going to cause
every cross-section effectively to
increase if you're doing this average
scenario let's talk a little bit about
why it's not it's not as simple as just
saying the cross-sections go up so let's
say we had two different temperatures
cold and hot so this would be your Sigma
fission cold and this would be your
Sigma fission hot for cold Sigma fission
looks something like that
and as the temperature goes up these
resonances which I'll just label right
here resonances being specific energy is
where the absorption suddenly goes up
suddenly goes down will actually
decrease in height but they'll start to
spread out more that's about as well as
I can draw it very crudely and same
thing goes well not just for Sigma
fission but for Sigma anything including
absorption including total whatever you
want and so if your goal is to get your
neutrons from the fast region where
they're born into the thermal region
where you get fission broadening these
cross-sections makes it more likely that
if the neutron loses any amount of
energy it's going to hit one of these
big resonance regions and get absorbed
or taken away before it gets a chance to
go to the fission region so what this is
really going to do it's it's kind of
funny to say it in terms of a one group
criticality relation but your fission
cross-sections actually gonna go down
one reason is that the fuel physically
spreads out and so this just from the
density modification you're not going to
get as much but then you've also got
that effect of increasing fission from
these resonance regions spreading out
the question is which one is a bigger
effect
I can't answer that with a simplest
statement you'll go over a lot more of
that in 2205 when you talk about what
actually defines a residence region how
do you calculate them and how do they
Doppler broaden our broaden with
temperature
how about Sigma absorption yeah Sigma
absorption well it's gonna go down
because things spread out but it might
also go up because the the cross
sections spread out or the residence is
spread out what's really gonna happen
though is the reactor atoms are
effectively like spreading themselves
apart the coolants less dense the
structural materials in the fuel and
everything are still there they're less
dense but there's not few of them in the
reactor but there is going to be less
coolant in the reactor because it has
the ability to spar safai or get less
dense and kind of squeeze out the inlet
and outlet of the reactor so what's
really gonna happen here is we know
diffusions going to go up which might
cause a corresponding change in buckling
and the net effect as we would hope k
effective would go down and so what
we've talked about now here is directly
controlling reactivity with control rods
what's called a void coefficient where
you actually want to have a negative
void coefficient so if you boil your
coolant too much K effective should go
down and that's one of the mechanisms
that a light water or thermal reactor
can help stabilize itself and you can
see that now from just the really
simplified one group criticality rate
relation and if you raise the fuel
temperature let's say the fuel gets
really hot because there's been some
power spike you also want the reactor to
shut itself down which you can see that
it does let's make things a little
trickier
let's now talk about a sodium reactor
fast reactor this one relies a lot more
on fast fission of u-238 so if we were
to draw the two cross-sections of 235
Sigma fission and 238 Sigma fission
remember uranium-235 looked like the one
that we drew before whereas you 238 go
something like that with no actual scale
given I'm not going to even go there but
uranium 238 does not need moderation for
the neutrons to induce more fission so
let's now write the same criticality
reaction which again is a super
simplified view of things but that's
okay what would happen to each of these
terms in a sodium fast reactor if you
void the coolant
so new won't change what about Sigma
fission well if the coolant goes away
then on average there's fissile
materials contributing more to that
cross-section but not that much so do
you want to get technical might be the
slightest of increases but doesn't
matter that much what really matters
though is the stuff on the bottom sodium
does have a low but non negligible
absorption cross-section so if the
sodium were to boil away then the
absorption would go down by a non
negligible amount and then what about
diffusion
well we've got the formula for it up
there if there's not as much coolant in
the way then the neutrons of God I got
are gonna be able to get further on on
average let's say they're not going to
be scattering around with as much of the
sodium so there might be a small
increase in diffusion and corresponding
small increase in buckling but this is
where the one group kind of fails right
what the sodium is actually doing is
providing a little bit of moderation so
that some of those neutrons when they
bounce off of sodium leave the fast
fission region and get absorbed and
that's part of the balance of the
reactor if all of the neutrons are then
born fast and don't really slow down and
just get absorbed then you might have an
overall positive void coefficient so
this would tell you that in a fast
reactor where you're depending on your
coolant not just to cool the reactor but
to absorb somewhat and to moderate some
what you don't want to boil the coolant
in a fast reactor and this is a lot of
the reason why most fast reactor
coolants tend to have extremely high
boiling points sodium is approximately
893 Celsius LED business is
approximately 1670 Celsius molten salts
about 1,400 Celsius so those all those
cool ins except for the sodium one
you'll melt the steel that the reactor
is made out of before your boil to
coolant so boiling the coolant is a bad
day in a fast reactor because then
things will go from bad to worse because
in this case the feedback coefficient
can be positive for voiding the coolant
that's no good so you want to keep the
reactor submerged and that's another
reason why a lot of these fast reactors
are what's called pool type reactors the
reactor is not a vessel with a bunch of
piping under it that can break and fail
but instead it's designed as a huge pool
of liquid sodium and then the core is
somewhere in here with a bunch of pumps
sending the coolant in and back out or
through some heat exchanger or something
so there's not really any penetrations
on the bottom of this pool and you make
sure that you maintain either when you
have sodium or lead bismuth eutectic or
a liquid lead or some other fast reactor
coolant so these are some kind of
interesting scenarios to think about I
think one of them that I put in the
homework was imagine you have the MIT
reactor and replace the coolant with
molten sodium what's going to happen
well let's say you got all the water out
first and it wouldn't just blow up right
what would actually happen to the
criticality relation that's something I
want you to think about because one of
the big problems on the homework is
doing exactly this for scenarios that
have happened to the MIT reactor except
for the sodium one that's never happened
and hopefully never will yeah I can't
even imagine but so now let's talk a
little bit about when you perturb a
reactor by doing something to it putting
the control rods in or pulling them out
or doing whatever you want you're by
definition going to take one of our
first assumptions about how the neutron
diffusion equation works and throw it
out the window so we're now moving into
the transient regime so to study what
happens in a reactor transient or when
something changes as a function of time
let's first go from K effective to what
we call K infinity the multiplication
factor for an infinite medium we're only
doing this because it's analytically
easier to understand and still gets the
point across so we'll say that our K
infinity is still a balance between
production and destruction the
difference is if we have an infinite
medium there's no leakage you can't leak
out of an infinitely sized reactor
should one ever exist and so it just
comes out as new Sigma fission over
Sigma absorption a much simpler form and
so now we can write what would happen to
the flux in the reactor as a function of
time and in this case is gonna be one
over velocity I'm going to make this a
very obvious wide V that change in the
reactor flux is going to just be
proportional to the imbalance now in the
number of neutrons produced and
destroyed so the number of neutrons
produced would be proportional to very
sharp new Sigma fission minus the number
of neutrons destroyed Sigma absorption
times Phi as a function of T you all
with me so far so this right here is a
change which is proportional to an
imbalance between production and
destruction times the actual flux that
you have in some given time so to make
the simpler let's multiply everything by
V where's my green substitute color
multiply everything by V and the only
unfortunate situation is we have a
Vienna knew next to each other I'm going
to try to keep them looking really
different those go away and then we end
up with if we divide by Phi and those
Phi's go away and we have v prime over
Phi equals V nu Sigma fission minus V
Sigma absorption and now we can start to
define things in terms of our K infinity
factor and a new quantity I'd like to
introduce called the prompt lifetime
it's a measure of how long a given
Neutron tends to live before something
happens to it before it's either
absorbed or leaks out well not from our
infinite reactor and so we can define
this as 1 over their Neutron Vil
ASSA tea time Sigma absorption and just
to check the unit's here velocities in
meters per second
macroscopic cross-sections are in one
over meters so those cancel out and
we're left with a total units of seconds
that's nice we would want a mean Neutron
lifetime or a prompt lifetime to have
units of seconds or time at least yep
why the DV DT squared went away okay so
that's because we assume we're gonna be
analyzing an infinite medium so right
here this two real able these terms this
would be the total production term that
right there represents absorption and
that right there represents leakage but
if we're analyzing an infinite medium
you can't leak out because it takes up
the entire universe and Beyond depending
on what you believe metaphysically or
whatever anyway that's different costs
so this right here we can rewrite as 1
over lifetime that makes it easier and
this right here if we note that new SiC
that's a new I'm gonna be really
explicit about that new Sigma fission
over Sigma absorption this kind of looks
like well this is looking to be like K
whoops wrong color like RK infinity over
LP so all of a sudden we have a much
simpler relation we have v prime over
Phi equals K infinity minus 1 over the
prompt Neutron lifetime so if we solve
this this is just the next
financial so we end up with our Phi as a
function of T is whatever flux we
started at like for your power in amid
manipulations it would be whatever the
Neutron flux was before you touch the
control rod times e to the T or e to the
that stuff
okay infinity minus one over L P times T
which we can rewrite as T over capital T
where we're going to define this symbol
as what's called the reactor period the
reactor period actually measures how
what the reactor period actually says is
how long before the flux increases by a
factor of e
and so this is actually what that meter
was measuring on the reactor it's the
reactor period or the time it would then
take for the reactors power to increase
by a factor of e because it's an
exponential to tell you what these
typical reactor periods tend to be for a
thermal reactor T is about 0.1 seconds
corresponding to an average prompt
Neutron lifetime of 10 to the minus 4
seconds seems fast doesn't it like
really fast so the question I ask to you
guys is why don't reactors just blow up
yes there is something we've neglected
from here it's like what Sarah said and
it deserves its own board there is a
fraction of delayed neutrons well good
well give that fraction the symbol beta
and for a uranium 235 it equals about
point Oh Oh 6 4 so there's less than a
percent of all the neutrons coming out
of a reactor have some delay to them
because they're not made directly from
fission in the 10 to the minus 14
seconds that we talked about in the
timeline but they come out of
radioactive decay processes with delayed
lifetimes ranging from about 0.2 seconds
to about 54 seconds this is the whole
reason why reactors don't just blow up
so you can actually make a reactor go
supercritical but if the K effective is
less than 1 plus beta then the reactor
is not what we call prompt supercritical
and so the reason for that is let's say
you raise the reactor power by some
amount and the K effective goes up to
like one point zero five there's still
this fraction point zero six four of the
neutrons are not going to be released
immediately they're gonna be released
not in ten to the minus fourteen seconds
but in like ten to the two seconds so
you know amis Li 15 orders of magnitude
slower meaning that there's actually
some ability for this reactor to raise
its power level and these delayed
neutrons even though that's such a small
fraction takes the reactor period from
its T infinity value of about 0.1
seconds to about a hundred seconds so
the same reactor when you account for
the delayed neutrons increases in power
by a factor of e and it takes it about a
hundred seconds which means this is
totally controllable now I have a
question for you guys would you guys
like me to derive this formula or do you
want to go into more of the intuitive
implications of it because we can go
either way there is a formula that will
tell you what the reactor period and
time dependence will be and you will hit
it in 22:05 probably I can't guarantee
it cuz I'm not teaching it or we can
talk a little bit more about some of the
intuition behind delayed neutrons so a
bit of your choose-your-own-adventure
math or intuition intuition okay that's
fine good so that that was the route
that was the derivation I'll post that
anyway if you guys want to see says I
think in the yep reading it says like
okay let's account for the delayed
neutrons intuitively we find that the
answer ends up being so I'll skip the
derivation and it comes out - oh boy
find out eetu the
beta minus 1 times K minus 1 over L T
plus beta Phi naught over beta minus 1 K
minus 1 times 1 minus e to the beta
minus 1 K minus 1 over L ok so left as
an exercise to the reader yeah that's
intuitive so but let's actually talk
about how intuitive it is I do want to
give you the starting and the ending
equation and we will not go through the
rest yeah charlie no you should it I'm
gonna I'm gonna scan it for you guys so
don't bother copying it down let's talk
about where it comes from and the answer
may astound you because we're gonna
bring right back the idea of series
radioactive decay so let's say you had
you want to relate the change in the
number in the neutron flux to a 1 minus
I'm gonna take a quick look at the
original equation so I don't want to
screw that up that's the first page and
that's the one we want let's say we had
some equation that looked something like
this 5 plus 5 naught times beta this is
the original differential equation from
once it came and the intuitive part that
I want you to note is that the jump from
changing K effective is moderated by
this term right here 1 minus beta so
that's the fraction of prompt neutrons
that as soon as you pull the control rod
out that's your instantaneous feedback
by instantaneous I mean on the order of
like 10 to the minus 4 seconds or
something you can't really control this
right here represents the delayed
fraction this is as mathy as it's gonna
get because you have chosen intuition I
think you have chosen wisely it's gonna
be a lot more fun so what this
represents right here is a kind of
instant change because whatever you
change K effective to is going to be
moderated by the prompt fraction how
long the neutrons tend to take to
undergo that feedback yeah Sara the
average one yes this is the average
Neutron lifetime so let's define the
average Neutron lifetime as simply 1
minus beta times the prompt Neutron
lifetime plus the I'm sorry beta times
some delayed Neutron lifetime so what no
book I've ever seen actually says this
is what's referred to as a Maxwell
mixing model it's just the simplest
thing to say oh if you want to get the
average of some variable take the
fraction of one species times its
variable plus the fraction of the other
species times its variable folks do the
same thing with electrical resistivity
thermal conductivity or any sort of
other material property and it is or
isn't good in some situations like if
you had a piece of material made out of
two different things
let's say this had thermal conductivity
taewon that had thermal conductivity k -
what a Maxwell mixing model be
appropriate to describe the flow of heat
across this thing probably not but in
the case of neutrons where they're
flying about like crazy and they're mean
free path is much larger than the
distance between atoms this works great
so we can define this mean
neutron lifetime and use that in this
equation right here so this term right
here describes the instantaneous change
you pull the control rods out and
fraction 1 minus beta neutrons respond
immediately what about that fraction of
neutrons those are being produced with a
fraction beta depending on what the flux
was before because they're still waiting
to decay from the old power level does
anyone notice anything suspicious Li
familiar about the final form of this
equation for flux you've seen it before
with a couple of constants changed
around what about the form of this
differential equation it is exactly the
same as series radioactive decay so the
horrible derivation I was going to do
for you guys and we're not anymore
is use an integrating factor you solve
it in exactly the same way you bring
everything to one side of the equation
find some factor mu that makes this a
product rule do a lot of algebra and you
end up with a very suspiciously similar
looking equation so it's exactly the
same posing and solution as series
radioactive decay with the difference
being that's the constant in front of
everything it's instead of a bunch of
lambdas and fluxes so what this says
here is that the flux as a function of
time this is the prompt feedback right
here which says that if let's graph it
since we're going intuitive there's no
room
yeah even those all boards are full ok
here we go if we graph time and flux
right here what that part right there
says is that you're going to get some
sort of instantaneous exponential
feedback but it's going to be moderated
by this 1 minus
on top so you're gonna end up with a
little bit of prompt feedback this stuff
right here and then have to draw longer
because it's gonna take forever you'll
have some delayed feedback because
you've got to wait a hundred or so
seconds or whatever that new reactor
period is for the delayed neutrons to
take effect and that's the whole reason
you could pull the control rods out at
almost any speed you wanted and the
reactor doesn't just explode if you pull
the control rods out fast enough such
that the change in K effective is
greater than beta then the reactor goes
prompt supercritical which means you
don't have any delayed neutrons slowing
down the feedback and you've kind of
turned your reactor into a weapon a very
poor terrible weapon but a prompt
supercritical nuclear device nonetheless
did anybody pull out the control rods
too fast and the controls took over for
you what about you guys in training did
you ever do things when you watch the
cotta Matic control take over no that's
what I mean is is the machine takes over
and it will kick you off right and stop
responding to you I see but the annoying
alarm is to stop you from doing
something like that like making the
reactor go prompt supercritical okay so
that's what I would call the Machine
taking over
yeah okay so if your blood-alcohol level
is above beta and you try and let's say
increase the reactor reactivity too much
it will then take over insert a control
rod make a horrible noise and say go
home you're drunk something like that
okay that makes sense to me
so what did your guyses reactor power
traces look like did they look something
like this
where there was an initial rise as you
pulled the control rod out and then
after you pulled the control rod out the
power kept rising just a smidge right
and what happened when you put the
control rod back in let's say you put
the control rod back in you're gonna get
another prompt to drop not equal to the
same prompt gain that you got because
now the reactors at a different flux and
then some asymptotic feedback like that
and so this is why to those who don't
understand Neutron physics reactor
feedback is very non-intuitive it's not
a linear system you can't just pull the
control rod out and change the power
accordingly this is why there's animated
controls and systems to stop you in case
like I said if your blood alcohol
content suppose beta which is very low
by the way you shouldn't be drinking on
the job especially at a nuclear reactor
plus you're all under 21 so what am I
even saying okay that's right good
answer
what is alcohol that'll be on the exam
yeah yeah cool so that's all I want to
go into for the intuitive stuff and it's
about 5 of 5 of so I'd like to stop here
and see if you guys have any questions
on Neutron physics at a-hole noting that
we're gonna take Thursday's class and
turn into a recitation so I would like
all of you guys to look at the problem
set because it is posted it is hard
trust me this one's a doozy so I want to
warn you guys because you got 7 days to
work on it but I want you to look at it
so that we can start formulating
strategies for the problems together on
Thursday because there are some tricks
to it as usual if you guys know me by
now right there's always some sort of a
trick like do you have to integrate
every energy to get the stopping power
no you actually don't have to do any
integrals at all but you can if you want
and your answer will be more accurate
and correct it'll just take longer to
get to so there's a lot of diminishing
returns on these problem sets if you're
willing to take an hour and think about
how can I do this simpler and with fewer
decimal points you're probably on to
something and we'll work on those
strategies together yes yeah so I posted
it yesterday at around noon or whatever
the stellar site says yeah I'll also
teach you guys sort of explicitly how to
use Janus so we got a comment in from
the anonymous feedback saying we have to
use a lot of software can we have some
sort of tutorial for dummy as well you
guys aren't dummies but you still
deserve a tutorial so I will show you
how to export the data you'll need from
this problem set for Janus so you can
focus on the intuition in the physics
and not get frustrated with getting data
out of a computer so any questions on
anything from the neutron diffusion
equation yeah Luke the prompt neutrons
come right out of fission if we looked
at that time line of let's say the
fission event happens here to fission
products are released in about 10 to the
minus 14 seconds they move a little
further apart and then some of them just
boil off neutrons because they're so
Neutron heavy after around like I would
is at 10 to the minus 13 seconds or so
these right here are prompt neutrons
coming directly from the immediate decay
of Neutron rich fission products some of
the delayed neutrons come from
radioactive decay but of the much later
fission products
with much less likely occurrences which
is why the fractions very low but also
because it's much longer half-life those
delayed neutrons take seconds instead of
picoseconds to show up that's the whole
basis behind easier control and feedback
of reactor good question
so anything starting from neutron
transport to simplifying to Neutron
diffusion to getting to this criticality
condition making the to group get a
criticality condition if you want to
let's say have fast and thermal or any
of the time-dependent stuff that we
intuited today yeah was it on the other
border from a different day yes so in
this case let me get a finer chalk this
blue one would be for low temperature
and this red one would be for high
temperature so this blue graph there are
resonances which have very high values
but they're very narrow and because the
width of a resonance doesn't matter it
doesn't affect the probability that a
neutron scatters up here and moves some
distance down the energy spectrum
thinner resonances get tend to get
passed over especially like if your
reactors full of hydrogen some of those
neutrons will be born and immediately
jump into the thermal region where it's
easy to tell how much fission they'll
undergo as you go up in temperature you
undergo what's called Doppler broadening
which causes these resonances to spread
out and also go down in value so the
actual value of the cross-section at
these residences is lower but the widths
are larger so there's a higher
probability that a neutron scattering
around and losing energy will hit one of
these higher cross-section regions call
the resonance at a higher temperature
that's the difference there is these two
plots show the same cross-section at low
and high temperature these plots show
the difference between uranium-235 and
uranium-238 good question anyone else
cool ok well for the first time in
history I'll let you out a minute early
bring all your questions on Thursday so
we'll start off with a janice tutorial
and then we'll start attacking this
problem set together